we're continuing to remember
the 13 u.s service members lost in last
week's terror attack at karzai
international airport in kabul that was
the one that caused by joe biden's
reckless exit from afghanistan remember
he could have done it when we actually
had full control of kabul and his
reckless abandonment of our fellow
americans now behind enemy lines 13
lives they were the best
america had to offer our national
treasure young bright selfless
people willing to put their lives on the
line for all of us to serve their
country joining us now is the sister and
the father of u.s marine lance corporal
riley mccollum
royce mccollum and jim mccollum
i jim first of all to both of you i
i don't know how you recover i really
don't i don't know how you deal with
something as tragic as this
what angers me the most is it was
preventable
because we saw they were on the march he
knew that they were on the march and he
didn't lift a finger
and when we had control of kabul we
could have withdrawn our troops our
allies taken our equipment home with us
or destroyed it do something but give it
to them
i don't know i i have a hard time
absorbing the circumstances your
thoughts and my deepest sympathies and
prayers
for you and your family
thank you very much and you described
all 13 of them
perfectly just selfless
the best america had to offer
and i
i agree with you 100 and that's one of
the reasons i chose not to speak with
president biden is
everything he has done was completely
wrong
we had opportunities to do this the
right way and and we absolutely failed
miserably as a as an administration um i
can't blame the entire thing on one
administration it goes back you know
we're 20 years into this
um
but
when when it came down to pulling
pulling people out and pulling troops
out and leaving the country it's not a
worse way there was no you couldn't have
picked a worse way to go about it
you know royce i'm looking at these
pictures of you and your brother and
your dad and i'm like i mean it's just
heartbreaking
i know there was a lot of press i'm not
going to press you to talk about
politics any more than you want to i'm
not i've you you've suffered enough pain
but there was the meeting with one
particular
family you decided not to meet with joe
biden your family
and
he met with the marines pregnant widow
and described it as a
the widow described it as a scripted
total disregard to the service member's
death and
you told this story to the washington
post
and i got to be honest i was grateful
that you said it
you know you can't f up as bad as he did
and say you're sorry
um
i'm sorry i applaud you for saying it i
really do and that's how i feel
and i'm not going to lie about how i
feel
because i feel for you and your dad as
you you sit there and having to live
through this i feel for this pregnant
mother this child will never meet
their father ever
and as a father i could tell you i don't
know how i'd recover
that happened to someone in my family
tell us about your thoughts um yeah gigi
my other older sister
sat with her um and she ended up having
to get up and leave um he didn't even
mention riley uh never said their names
to any parent as far as i'm aware
um it was immediately he came in
with his story about his son who served
um and it's like that is not even
remotely the same thing um your son as
it's still tragic and he died of cancer
and that is sad but it is not even close
to the same situation um and there was
again no mention of riley no i'm sorry
for your loss it was my son died too um
and you know you tapped around the leg
and she pulled away twice and then he
got up and went and talked to another
family um a lot of the other families
that he talked to he spoke with a lot
longer but only because they carried on
the conversation to
really share their thoughts with him
otherwise i i'm pretty sure it probably
would have been a two-minute
conversation to each family mostly about
his son and he would have just walked it
out it was walked it
walked out
it was it was more about him
i hope you don't ever apologize please
media is going to say oh you gotta never
because that was real that was raw and i
get it and i applaud you for your
honesty
you know
sir i know this is your son
i i read your comments apparently your
son was in the middle of pulling all
these people to safety
they were warned that this this was
coming
your son stayed there
and he was
saving as many people as he can
you know
i can quote the bible it says no great
no man had greater love than to lay down
their life for someone else
that's your son embodied that
i don't think he would have left
unless there was an order to get out of
there i don't think he would have left
um
it's just the way they were they were
there for a mission that whole unit
um
that's just who they are they're gonna
do what they need to do
the humanitarian
uh efforts that they were they were
doing i think they all lived that and
they loved it and they knew they were
doing something to help other people
i don't know that you could have got him
away from where he was
you know
that's a special that's a special human
being your son was a special human being
royce your brother is a special human
being
and i truly believe in all my heart that
you'll meet him again in paradise one
day and that he knows your love for him
and we appreciate you sharing your story
with us
and i'm so sorry this happened to you
and your family and your son and your
brother thank you for being with us
thank you appreciate that